[Musique]
bonsoir à tous merci de votre attention
voici les titres de l'actualité de ce
mardi Jacques Chirac choisit un fidèle
Dominique de Villepin est nommé Premier
ministre en remplacement de Jean-Pierre
rafarin il s'est installé en fin
d'après-midi à l'Hôtel Matignon après
une brêve cérémonie de passation des
pouvoirs dans quelques instants
l'intervention du président de la
République il devrait tracer la feuille
de route du nouveau chef du gouvernement
un gouvernement qui devrait marquer le
retour de Nicolas Sarkozi une place de
choix numéro 2 et ministre de
l'intérieur tout en conservant la
présidence de l'UMP c'est une surprise
le reste de l'équipe sera connu demain
ou après-demain les chiffres du chômage
pour la première fois depuis le début de
l'année il a très légèrement reculé en
avril Mo- 01 % mais le nombre de jeunes
sans emploi a encore augmenté la dérive
autoritaire de Vladimir Poutine en
Russie le milliardaire kodorkovski rival
potentiel du chef du kremelin a été
condamné à 9 ans de prison ferme la
Journée mondiale sans tabac on verra
qu'en France la consommation de
cigarettes ne diminue plus après une
baisse de plusieurs années enfin Roland
Garos c'est le printemps de Marie Pierce
à 30 ans la Française a battu la numéro
1 mondiale ins Aven port et se is dans
le dernier carré chez les hommes la
première demi-finale opposera les deux
favoris Nadal et
FEDER et tout de suite donc direction
l'Élysée 48 he après le référendum
Jacques Chirak a donc nommé un nouveau
Premier ministre il va maintenant
s'adresser au
français
[Musique]
mes chers compatriotes de métropole
d'autrem et de
l'étranger le 29 mai le référendum sur
la Constitution européenne a ouvert pour
l'Europe et pour la France une période
de difficultés et
d'incertitude et dans cette période nous
devons nous rassembler autour de
l'intérêt
national ce vote de marque pas le rejet
de l'idéal européen c'est une demande
d'écoute c'est une demande d'action
c'est une demande de
résultat des attentes fortes diverses et
parfois contradictoires se sont exprimé
elles se rejoignent dans un sentiment
d'insatisfaction et d'ins
face au monde
d'aujourd'hui après les grandes réformes
qui ont été faites pour lever les
handicaps accumulé dans le passé et pour
préparer l'avenir vous en appelez à une
action déterminée et immédiate pour
répondre plus vite aux difficultés du
présent qu'il s'agisse du chômage ou du
pouvoir
d'achat pour mettre en œuvre cette
action j'ai décidé de donner une
nouvelle impulsion à la politique de la
France aujourd'hui Jean-Pierre rafarin
m'a remis la démission de son
gouvernement en 3 ans dans des
conditions difficiles il a accompli pour
la France une œuvre de redressement que
je veux
saluer il a rétabli l'autorité de l'État
et fait reculer
l'insécurité il a créé les conditions du
redémarrage de notre
économie a conduit la réforme des
retraites et celle de l'Assurance
Maladie réforme qui était
indispensable pour préserver nos régimes
sociaux et donc pour préserver le
principe fondamental de l'égalité de
tous les Français devant la sécurité
social et malgré les difficultés des
réformes il a toujours su agir dans un
esprit d'ouverture et de dialogue je
tiens à rendre chaleureusement hommage à
sa personne
et à son
action face à la situation actuelle
comme à d'autres moments difficiles de
notre histoire il nous faut réagir nous
rassembler surmonter nos difficultés et
dépasser nos blocages pour faire
progresser notre
pays le vote du 29 mai a ouvert c'est
vrai une période
difficile dans le respect du message des
Françaises et des Français la France
doit agir car l'Europe démultiplie nos
forces on ne peut pas vouloir préserver
notre modèle économique et social on ne
peut pas vouloir porter nos valeurs dans
le monde sans tenir toute notre place
dans
l'Europe dans les semaines et les mois
qui viennent j'agirai dans le respect de
nos
engagements avec pour impératif la
défense de nos intérêts nationaux
avec nos partenaires je saisirai toutes
les chances possibles de renouer avec
une grande ambition
européenne mais la priorité de l'action
gouvernementale au service des
Françaises et des Français c'est
évidemment l'emploi il exige une
mobilisation
nationale cette mobilisation je suis
décidé à l'inscrire résolument dans le
respect de notre modèle
français ce modèle n'est pas un modèle
de type
anglo-saxon mais ce n'est pas non plus
un modèle synonyme
d'immobilisme c'est un modèle fondé sur
le dynamisme et l'initiative
individuel sur la solidarité et sur le
dialogue social
l'urgence ce n'est pas d'ajouter des
textes au textes c'est l'engagement
résolu de tous les acteurs quand sil
s'agit de la croissance du chômage de la
précarité aucune solution ne doit être
écartée par
préjugé aucune ne doit être
découragée le seul critère est celui de
l'efficacité le gouvernement s'engagera
résolument dans cette voie j'appelle au
même engagement les entreprises et les
syndicats car ce qui est en jeu c'est de
démontrer qu'en agissant
ensemble avec à l'esprit le seul intérêt
national nous sommes capables de gagner
la bataille de l'emploi tout en restant
nous-mêmes T est mes chers compatriotes
la mission essentielle que j'ai décidé
de confier à Dominique de
Villepin parce qu'il a l'autorité la
compétence et l'expérience
nécessaire et parce que dans la
compétition mondiale pour l'activité et
pour l'emploi il sait que la France si
elle s'en donne les moyens à la capacité
d'être forte à condition d'être fidèle à
ses traditions républicaine et fidèle à
son pacte
social je lui ai demandé de constituer
une équipe unie et déterminé qui fassent
toute leur place aux compétences et aux
talents une équipe s'appuyant sur
l'engagement personnel des responsables
de la
majorité dans un esprit de rassemblement
j'ai demandé à Nicolas Sarkozi de
rejoindre le gouvernement comme ministre
d'État ce qui l'a accepté mes chers
compatriotes face à ces défis face à
l'ambition qui doit être la nôtre nous
ne réussirons que si nous sommes
rassemblés et animés par un esprit de
dialogue rassembler sans esprit partisan
avec le seul souci de l'intérêt général
et de la just JCE rassembler pour ne pas
ajouter le risque de la division aux
difficultés qu'il nous faut prendre àras
Lecor dans la période qui s'ouvre vous
pouvez compter sur mon engagement et sur
ma
détermination pour faire vivre et
progresser le modèle français vive la
république et vive la
France voilà pour cette intervention du
chef de l'État 2 jours après la du
référendum le président de la République
veut donc reprendre la main vous l'avez
entendu pour remplacer jean-pierrefarin
il a choisi un fidèle parmi les fidèles
Dominique de Villepin le récit de ces
dernières heures Jean-Baptiste
pr ils ont l'air ravi pour l'un tout
commence pour l'autre c'est déjà l'après
matigon ce matin il y était venu comme
au bureau les appartements privés ét
déjà
vitination
connaissait son tret du jour direction
donc l'Élysée jean-pierrearin sait ce
qu'il va dire àcirac le 18 mai il lui a
indiqué qu'il ne voulait pas poursuivre
à matigon après le référendum là c'est
officiel le Premier ministre a remis sa
démission jacquesirattarde avec lui sur
le Peron de l'Élysée lui repart un autre
arrive un chassé croisé de Premier
ministre enfin pas encore enfin
presque le Premier ministre s'il vous
plaît pour Jean-Pierre affarin l'Élysée
a des égards fait exceptionnel l'ancien
Premier ministre annonce lui-même sa
démission devant ses collaborateurs il
évoque son bilan et à demi-mot son
impopularité en citant de Gaulle enfin
avec le gouvernement et la majorité j'ai
toujours eu conscience que ce qui est
salutaire pour la nation ne va pas sans
blâ dans l'opinion tous les
gouvernements européens font face à
cette vérité du général de B une affaire
de minute la nouvelle est tombée venue
de l'Élysée Dominique de Villepin et
bien le nouveau Premier ministre et son
premier geste lui qui n'a jamais été élu
ni même candidat c'est d'aller déjeuner
avec les parlementaires de l'UMP à
l'Assemblée auprès des députés c'est sûr
matigon rend populaire et le président
de l'Assemblée doit même jouer les
gardes du
corps 16h le grand moment Dominique de
villep entre ENF à matigon il vient
rejoindre son prédécesseur une heure de
revue de dossier et peut-être quelques
conseils dans la cour et aux fenêtres
les membres du personnel patiente les
collaborateurs de jeanpierrearin sont au
spectacle
enfin ils
sortent on applaudit surtout celui qui
s'en va et Dominique de Villepin
prononce ses premiers mots de Premier
ministre je
veux rendre
hommage à l'action
courageuse et déterminée de Jean-Pierre
rafarin dernière bise et c'est bientôt
le départ pour l'un Jean-Pierre rafarin
rentre chez lui 1122 jours à Matignon et
mot de la fin bonnes vacan à vous
qu'est-ce que vous allez faire
maintenant faire Dominique de Villepin a
51 ans on l'a dit c'est un chirakien du
premier cercle connu pour son style
flamboyant mais il ne s'est jamais
présenté face aux électeurs on l'a
entendu et il devra convaincre y compris
dans son propre camp portrait signé
Véronique
Saint-Olive 1995 Dominique de Villepin a
42 ans quand le président de la
République le nomme secrétaire général
de l'Élysée et en fait son plus proche
collaborateur l'ancien directeur de
cabinet d'Alain Jupé est ferru de poésie
admirateur de Napoléon passionné
certains dénoncent aussi son arrogance
et ses grands airs d'autant que c'est
lui qui en 97 encourage la
dissolution j'ai décidé de dissoudre
l'Assemblée
nationale opération ratée c'est un ras
demaré à gauche la droite est vend
debout contre l'influent conseiller mais
Jacques Chirac lui maintient sa
confiance sa Foug en fait l'un des
artisans essentiels de la réélection de
Jacques Chirac en 2002 il est alors
nommé
okorset le nouveau ministre des Affaires
étrangères se bat sur tous les fronts
les Narc Diplomat révèle le guerrier
gestion des conflits de la planète et le
deè attentatit un peu plus c'est vrai
que là on a une accélération très for
janvier 2003 en pleine crise de la Côte
d'Ivoire Dominique de Villepin affronte
en direct les manifestants d'Abidjan
mais l'image rarissime c'est le 24
février 2003 dans l'hémicycle de l'ONU
le ministre des Affaires étrangères
français est applaudi à tout rompre en
s'opposant aux Américains et à la guerre
en Irak Dominique de Villepin se
propulse au premier an de la diplomatie
mondiale c'est un vieux pays la France
d'un vieux continent comme le mien
l'Europe qui vous le dit aujourd'hui qui
a connu les gueres
l'occupation la barbarie panage gaulien
pour les uns arrogance maladroite pour
les autres ce jour-l en tout cas
Dominique de Villepin porte haut le
drapeau et les principes de la France un
an plus tard changement de terrain
Dominique de Villepin succède à Nicolas
SAR comme ministre de l'Intérieur autre
méthode autre
ton BA de la délinence de publ de 36%
c'est c'est pas banal donc bravo pour
gommer son image de
nonlu fait ses classes de premier flic
de France l'occasion d'exalter encore et
toujours l'honneur et la grandeur du
pays campagne pour le oui au référendum
avec un exercice nouveau pour lui celui
de la
proximité grand français un grand
Européen meeting médiia partout il
s'emploie à galvaniser quel que soit le
résultat du référendum qui le fr que les
Français votent oui ou qu'il votent non
il faudra une politique plus volon
encore plus volontaire encore plus
audacieuse encore plus solidaire ça ça
me paraît une vérité
d'évidence durant toutes ces dernières
semaines Dominique de Villepin a voulu
se poser en rassembleur mais en le
nommant àamatignon Jacques Chirac a pesé
aussi les risques le nouveau Premier
ministre devra calmer ses emballements
se faire accepter par des élus jusque-l
négligés supporter une cohabitation
difficile avec Nicolas Sarkozi et
surtout proposer aux Français désabusés
ou en colère une véritable alternative
Gill Leclerc nous a rejoint bonsoir
Gilles apparemment Jacques Chirac a
hésité il a beaucoup réfléchi alors
finalement pourquoi ce choix de
Dominique de Villepin il y a évidemment
un choix politique mais il y a d'abord
le choix d'un homme le choix de la
fidélité de la loyauté on s'en souvient
Jacques Chirac a toujours travaillé avec
des très proches Alain Jupé Jean-Pierre
afarin Dominique de Villepin demain il
ne pouvait s'agir à la tête de
l'exécutif d'une nouvelle cohabitation
difficile alors que déjà Jacques Chirac
était en difficulté l'autre raison
évidemment elle est politique c'est
l'image d'un Gauliste avec une certaine
vision de la France et de la France dans
le monde on vient de le voir une image
également d'un nouveau style conquérant
flamboyant avec du panache c'est
probablement aussi là-dessus que Jacques
Chirac compte pour provoquer peut-être
un électrochoc dans l'opinion publique
alors autre information de la journée
elle est désormais officielle puisque
Jacques Chirac vient de la confirmer
mais c'est une surprise Nicolas Sarkozi
fait son retour au gouvernement lui
aussi était candidat à Matignon il a
accepté de n'être que numéro 2 derrière
son rival en revanche il il a obtenu en
même temps un grand ministère de
l'Intérieur et le droit de conserver la
présidence de l'UMPS qui était jugé
incompatible il y a quelques semaines
encore Michael d'Armon David Fossard ça
l'a marqué dès qu'il croise un uniforme
il ne peut s'empêcher d'évoquer son
passage au ministère de
l'Intérieur de
vie moi j'ai dirigé les gendarmes les
policiers les douigners une nostalgie
qui remonte à ce jour-là il y a un an et
demi lorsqu'il laissait les clés du
ministère à Dominique
V j'ai vécu ici avec vous de années qui
compteront beaucoup dans ma vie le
travail qu'on a fait
ensemble je voudrais vous le dédier ah
merci les uniformes et les couvrechefs
change pas la méthode Alstom EDF le
pouvoir d'achat le marathon économique
et industriel
continue j'ai donc l'intention de me
battre sur tous les fronts en même temps
de bfor à Washington Nicolas Sarkozi
poursuit un objectif devenir
l'incontournable présidential de la
droite et alors que le ministre de
l'économie est sur la route de la
présidence à l'UMP Jacques Chirac
interdit le cumul des deux fonctions et
l'oblige à quitter le
gouvernement je n pas de regret ni
nostalgie j'étais très heureux pendant
pendant 3 ans et une nouvelle aventure
commence de nouvelles responsabilité
bien je vais essayer de mettre la même
énergie l'énergie le maître mot de
Nicolas Sarkozi quelques jours plus tard
le voit l'apporter au sommet de l'UMP le
parti
majoritaire j'irai dans les usines
j'irai dans les campagnes j'irai dans
les universités l'UMP devient son outil
de conquête mais au landemain du
référendum Nicolas Sarkozi consulté pour
Matignon se voit proposer de retourner à
l'intérieur en conservant la présidence
du parti c'est le branbat de combat dans
la Sarkozi et l'intéressé garde silence
à la mi-journée Nicolas Sarkozi
retrouvait son époux Cécilia à 200 m de
la place beauovau pour déjeuner un
indice en tout cas un symbole et si la
nomination de Dominique de Villepin
était relativement attendue la formation
de ce tandem avec Nicolas Sarkozi a pris
tout le monde par surprise est-elle
susceptible de mobiliser à l'intérieur
de la majorité réaction recueillie par
Émilie Lançon et Patrice bruger
Jean-Louis Debray salue ses visiteurs de
l'assemblée avant de saluer par le
commentaire cette fois son ami Dominique
V c'est le meilleur choix que on pouvait
faire parce que c'est un choix qui nous
rassemble et c'est un choix qui
rassemble l'ensemble des députés de la
majorité déjeuner à l'hôtel de laass
Dominique de Villepin qui n'a jamais été
élu au suffrage universel chouchoute les
députés eux sont sous le charme il
semblerait qu'à l'ONU les secrétaire
disait Dominique de Villepin oh comme il
est beau et bien je pense que les
français vont dire comme il est bon à
l'UMP on trouve même des députés qui ont
voté non au référendum et qui disent
bravo je pense que Dominique de Villepin
sincèrement comme Gauliste et amoureux
de la France est tout à fait capable de
réconcilier les oui et les non et pour
cela les députés de droite attendent un
changement de politique un changement
que pourrait favoriser Nicolas Sarkozi
qui devrait entrer dans le gouvernement
monsieur Sarkozi que je sache n'est pas
les de pieds dans le même sabot et
Monsieur de vilpin non plus reste à
savoir maintenant ce que le premier
ministre va nous proposer
s' nous propose un simple jeu de chaise
musicale s nous propose simplement une
adaptation d'une politique alors à ce
momentl il ne sera pas compris il ne
sera pas compis non plus par les
parlementaires après les députés la
tournée séduction continue Dominique de
villep a prévu de rencontrer les
sénateurs demain matin au palais du
Luxembourg alors Gill ce tandem est un
bon coup politique entre guillemets mais
les deux hommes sont rivaux on l'a dit
alors est-ce qu'ils pourront travailler
ensemble c'est vrai que c'est deux
styles qui n'ont rien à voir mais c'est
jacquesir qui a vraiment mis tout son
poids dans la balance pour convaincre
les deux hommes de s'entendre absolument
pourquoi bien l'objectif c'était de
sauver le quinena il reste 22 mois
seulement avant 2007 donc Jacques tiirac
on vient de l'entendre appel à l'union
appel au rassemblement et donc ces deux
hommes devront à tout prix travailler
ensemble mettre de côté les petites
phrases les rancœurs les rivalités pour
un seul but c'est-à-dire pour travailler
pour la France et d'abord la priorité
des priorité c'est-à-dire l'emploi ouis
mais il y a le choc des ambitions mais
il y a aussi de réelles divergences de
vue sur le modèle social français par
exemple là il y a il y a deux visions là
bien entendu encore dans la dans la
campagne récente disons que pour
Dominique de Villepin il y a une vision
je dirais un petit peu plus plus
Gauliste avec la culture l'histoire de
la France et puis on parle beaucoup avec
Dominique de Villepin du pacte
républicain avec Nicolas Sarkozi c'est
un peu une autre vision visiblement
séduit par le modèle anglo-saxon Nicolas
Sarkozi a voulu construire entièrement
son image plutôt sur la modernité de
modèles qui apparemment en tout cas sur
le papier ne sont pas tout à fait
conciliables il y a par exemple une
vraie différence de vue une vraie
divergence par exemple sur l'intégration
sur les problèmes d'intégration là les
deux hommes n'ont pas la même vision du
monde alors sur le papier en théorie
cela peut se gérer probablement au
quotidien quand il y aura crise cela
peut pourra tanguer éventuellement entre
les deux hommes et là il y aura un
arbitre cet arbitre sera évidemment le
président de la République merci Gill
alors ce changement de gouvernement a
été programmé mais il a tout le monde
l'a compris pour vocation de répondre au
malaise exprimé avanttiier lors du
référendum Jacques Chirac l'a rappelé
alors qu'en pense-t-on justement du côté
des partisans du nom mais aussi de
l'opposition ou encore des syndicats
réponse avec Alex
bouyaget Laurent Fabius très entouré
mais pe Locass merci de votre
gentillesse et allez bien déje pas
question de commenter lui-même la
nomination de Dominique de Villepin à
Matignon il laisse ça à ses
lieutenants c'est pas simplement parce
qu'on aura Sarkozi et vilpin qui vont se
marquer pour savoir lequel des deux
pourra prendre l'ascendance sur l'autre
que l'on réussira à répondre à la
demande qui existe de dans le pays d'un
are
politiqueconomique une fois n'est pas
coutume ce matin tous les socialistes
sont d'accord même le camp du I dit non
à la nomination Dominique de
villep qui ESP l'issue de ce référendum
il aura une politique plus social et
plus à gauche ils en sont je pense pour
leur
frais qu à qui à gauche comme à droite
fa dimanche soir en fanfare la victoire
du nom aujourd'hui aussi deschant et
face à ce cri et face à ce malaise on a
une réponse bricolage
institutionnel une pointe de crayon
entre eux ils font un gouvernement du
oui vraiment ce gouvernement n'écoute
rien n'entend
rien les syndicats eux jugeront l'homme
sur les actes et se projettent déjà dans
l'avenir la CFDT propose au
gouvernement de construire un Pact
social pour l'emploi et pour l'avenir
des salariés dans notre pays avec les
syndicats avec les organisations
patronales tous attendent avec une même
impatience le discours de politique
générale de dominiic de Villepin ce sera
le 7 juin prochain après l'opposition et
les leaders du nom la réaction des
électeurs eux-mêmes le changement
proposé est-il à la hauteur du choc de
dimanche dernier nous sommes allés dans
les quartiers nord de Marseille où le
nom a fait des scores très élevés
reportage Isabelle stess Christophe
laroka aujourd'hui le chef de l'État a
accepté la démission à leur grande
satisfaction Jean-Pierre aarin
démissionne c'est avant tout contre son
gouvernement que les Marseillais ont
voté non à plus de 61
%ou qui pens un peu à la pauvreté qui a
ici les petits travailleurs je suis
serveur je suis salarié comme on dit on
avance pas au lie d'avancer on recule
monsieur de villeepin va vous aider à
avancer je pense pas c'est c'est la même
assiette je pense pas monsieur
à la rigueur la rigueur oui dans le
match Villepin Sarkozi ce n'est pas
vraiment un jour de gloire pour le
nouveau Premier ministre dans ce café
populaire c'est une promotion pour de
villepince c'est pas une nouvelle
impulsion pour la France 15 % de chômage
un record pour une grandes villes les
quartiers nord ont voté non à 78 % il y
a plus de travail les les les les
salaires sont bas les disons que c'est
parfait pour eux pour les financiers
mais pas pour ceux qu' ont moi
j'aimerais qu'on remette le Fran que
depuis ce temps je galère he j'arrive en
milieu de moi je suis déjà découvert et
voilà quoi je je suis totalement paumée
deux arrondissements sur 16 ont voté oui
mais les attentes restent les mêmes je
suis pas concerné j'ai je gagne bien ma
vie j'ai pas de problème je suis
informaticien je suis ingénieur mais je
pense que le gros problème c'est
vraiment le chômage et c'est vraiment le
niveau social une page est tournée le
plus dur est à
faire alors on connaît le Premier
ministre le numéro 2 la composition du
gouvernement on l'a dit sera annoncé
demain ou après-demain une certitude
l'UDF n'y participera pas François
Baayou estime que le duo Villepin
Sarkozi je cite n'est pas à la hauteur
de la rupture attendue on
l'écoute cette annonce se fait
évidemment dans une ambiance d'opéra
bouff qui ressemble à tout sauf au
niveau requis pour traiter à la hauteur
qu'elle exigerait avec une imagination
nouvelle la situation de la France
déchirée Gill de Robien unique ministre
UDF de pierre afara devrait rester
ministre on parle d'ailleurs du
ministère de la Justice pour lui autre
hypothèse souvent évoquée ce soir
Thierry Breton resterait à l'économie et
aux finan Jean-Louis borlot resterait
aux affaires sociales Michel aliomarie
et Philippe doublasi devrai également
rester au gouvernement tout cela bien
sûr ce ne sont que des hiypothèse pour
beaucoup d'autres en tout cas c'est
l'incertitude certains commencent déjà à
faire les cartons Pauline revna jean- yy
blanc ici les cartons sont déjà faits au
ministère des Affaires européennes on
trie
on jette et on signe les derniers
papiers après un an passé au korset
claudieur sait qu'elle doit partir je
prends ma part de responsabilité sur le
fait que le message n'a pas été
suffisamment il a pas été suff possible
de le percevoir dans un contexte très
très difficile comme à chaque remanim
les ministres passent les fonctionnair
rest
terrible à chaque fois les G bon c'est
pas on sait pas ce que ce qu'on va
récupérer c'est pas évident du tout hein
autre tonalité au ministère de la
Fonction publique ici aucune certitude
on guettete nerveusement la sonnerie du
téléphone et on s'occupe comme on peut
il y a quand même le pincement qui est
là et on voit les les armoires se vider
on classe tout on archive mais c'est un
moment difficile c'est très difficile
partira partira pas chômage ou nouvelle
nomination derrière chaque ministre des
équipes inquies s'il n'y avait pas
remanement on pourrait croire à un grand
ménage de
printemps le chantier prioritaire du
nouveau gouvernement Jacques Chirac l'a
indiqué sera celui du chômage et bien le
dernier chiffre marque une légère
inflexion pour la première fois depuis
le début de l'année le nombre de sans
emplois a reculé mais reculé de 0,1 % en
avril 1400 chômeurs en moins le chômage
qui touche 10,2 % de la population
active et celui des moins de 25 ans en
revanche a continué à augmenter plus 0,6
% les jeunes restent la population la
plus touchée naalie mois
Laurent il aide même parfois à faire les
bouquets Fabrice Louveau n'avait
pourtant pas rêvé de travailler dans la
boutique de sa voisine mais après avoir
cherché un emploi d'ingénieur sans
succès pendant un an et demi il a dû se
résoudre à accepter ce poste de
comptable payé au
smic donc pour l'instant c'est
principalement
financier parce que à la fin du mois
j'ai besoin de d'avoir de l'argent pour
payer toutes mes factures et aussi pour
pour ne pas déprimer pour ne pas rester
chez moi inactif rester actif pour
trouver enfin un travail en rapport avec
son diplôme d'ingénieur en informatique
à 25 ans sans salaire pas d'indépendance
possible jusque- là fabrice a dû
retourner vivre chez ses parents salut
ça va va bien et toi car plus le temps
passe et plus la période d'inactivité
plombe le CV c'est le cercle
vicieux je faisais à peu près une dire 5
à si candidatures dans les meilleurs
temps par mois et donc la plupart était
négative il y a des moments où je
faisais où j'en faisais pas parce que
j'étais déprimé comme Fabrice il y a
encore quelques semaines 23 % des moins
de 25 ans sont sans emploi en France les
moins diplômés sont les plus touchés
mais les bac plus 4 ne sont pas épargnés
en 2003 seul un jeune diplômé sur de
avait un emploi un an plus
tard bousculade ce matin au palais de
Paris où qure nouveaux lycéens devaient
être jugés suite aux incidents qui ont
émaillé les manifestations des élèves
ont tenté de pénétrer en force dans la
salle d'audience Alb Mik
evelineman à coup de chaise en plastique
une soixantaine de manifestants tentent
de se frayer un chemin jusqu'à la salle
d'audience il voulaent s'inviter au
procès de deux de leurs proches
militants d'extrême gauche ils seront
expulsés manu
militar il ref l'accès à des jeunes qui
veulent venir assister au procès pour
pas Mo toute la matinée les incidents
vont se poursuivre devant la 24e chambre
à l'intérieur l'audience continue tant
bien que mal jugé pour dégradation et
violence volontaire en avril au lycée
felon deux jeunes en cours de sévèr
pénalités financièr pour leur avocat le
procès est avant tout
politique il faut savoir qu'en France
aujourd'hui plusieurs centaines
plusieurs centaines de lycéens sont
poursuivis pour des chefs d'incupation
qui sont graves qui sont complètement
infondés et disproportionnés par rapport
à ce qui a pu se passer
une fois le calme revenu l'audience a pu
s'achever le jugement est mis en
délibéré il sera prononcé le 14 juin
retour au calme à Perpignan quelques
incidents seulement la nuit dernière en
périphérie de la ville il faut dire que
le centre de Perpignan est quadrillé par
les forces de l'ordre plus de 1000
policiers au total et une partie de la
population reste barricadée sur place
léolandberton Françoise Mazou du jamais
vu d'ordinaire en plein après-midi le
quartier Saint-Jacques à perpignon est
noir de monde mais aujourd'hui les rues
sont vides la plupart des 5000 gitants
qui vivent là sont partis après les
émeutes de dimanche la psychose est
telle que ceux qui restent ne veulent
plus parler à visage découvert on amener
toutes les enfants et tous les les
femmes et les hommes ils sont revenus
parce qu'on a peur on n pas peur pour
nous mais pour pour les familles
certains des gitans de Saint-Jacques
nous les avons retrouvés à la périphérie
de la ville dans des cités dont les
entrées sont protégées par des camions
stationnés en chicane éébergé depuis
dimanche par la famille alors on en a
mal monsieur que la paix viennent qui
viennent à la paix parce qu'on ne mérite
rien nous autre communauté même peur
dans le quartier Saint-Mathieu beaucoup
d'enfants ne sont pas allés à l'école
c'est ici que dimanche un homme
d'origine marocaine a été assassiné et
les maghrébains se sentent en
danger j'ai pas dormi de la nuit j'ai
trois gosses là il dort j'habite au
premier étage j'ai aucun aucun confiance
maintenant ce soir entre les deux
communautés règne un équilibre précaire
au milieu 1000 policiers et gendarmes
font office de casque bleu pour quelques
jours encore justice avec la requête
d'un chef d'entreprise devant les
tribunaux accusé d'avoir assassiné sa
femme il a fait 3 ans de prison avant de
bénéficier d'un nonlieu il a dû brader
ses biens pour assurer sa défense et
s'occuper de ses quatre enfants il
demande aujourd'hui 3 millions et demi
d'euros Yann fronti Delphine paric
Miller ils l'ont toujours soutenu n'ont
jamais douté de son innocence
aujourd'hui c'est entouré de ces enfants
qu'andrecas est venu demander réparation
à la justice après 13 ans je demande
simplement une seule chose retrouver ce
que que j'ai perdu intégralement mon
père a travaillé toute sa vie on l'a peu
vu il est tout le temps en train de
travailler il a construit seul il est
parti de rien et en quelques années la
justice lui a fait tout perdre avant
d'être accusé de meurtre André cass
était un riche entrepreneur immobilier
propriétaire entre autres de cette
demeure en 1992 sa vie bascule sa femme
Sylviane est retrouvée assassinée dans
la maison familiale très vite l'enquête
le désigne comme le principal suspect
ruiné André casass va passer 3 ans en
prison avant d'être innocenté s'il
revient au tribunal aujourd'hui c'est
pour réclamer des dommages et intérêts
mais ce matin la justice ne lui a
proposé que 70000 € de réparation
difficile à accepter je suis extrêmement
déçu aujourd'hui je pense qu'il aurait
fallu un peu plus d'essessence qu'on
dise en effet c'était un truc
épouvantable quand on se trompe et quand
on met quelqu'un en prison bah au moins
on lui redonne ce qu'il a et tout ce que
je demande aujourd'hui c'est à retrouver
exactement ce que j'avais ni plus ni
moins que représente financièrement une
telle erreur judiciaire la cour d'appel
de rouan rendra sa décision le 27
juillet prochain à l'étranger la
condamnation à 9 ans de prison de l'ex
numéro 1 du pétrole russe le
milliardaire kodorkovski officiellement
pour fraude fiscale mais les défenseurs
des droits de l'homme en Russie
dénoncent un règlement de compte
politique qui confirme la dérive
autoritaire de Vladimir Poutine le
maître du kremelin aurait voulu ainsi
éliminer un de ses rivaux potentiels à
Moscou Anne Poncin et Xavier luouiset
c'est l'histoire de l'homme le plus
riche de Russie qui se retrouve jein
dans la cage du boxe des accusés aant de
sa splendeur on le voyait plutôt en
costume au kremelin quand Vladimir
Poutine rencontraiit les oligarques
Mirel rodorkovski côtoyait ses grands
barons d'industrie qui détiennent quasi
la moitié de l'économie russe des
fortunes vite faites lui c'était dans le
pétrole avec Yukos un groupe acheté pour
une bouchée de pain lors des
privatisation sauvag des années 90 il en
fait le premier groupe pétrolier russe
et évasion fiscale mauvais coup aux
actionnaires en affaire rorkovski n'a
pas toujours été un sain mais ses
collègues non plus seulement lui en plus
parle stratégie et se pique de politique
ça déplaît et au lieu de choisir l'exil
comme d'autres oligarques il reste en
Russie en 2003 il est arrêté accusé de
fraude fiscale une partie de son
entreprise est saisie et à l'issue d'une
étrange vente aux enchères retombe dans
l'escarcelle du cremelin les
investisseurs étrangers gourmand des
réserves de pétrole Russ
seritil en train de renationaliser
George B en parle mais la justice russe
poursuit l'opposition libérale a bien
essayé de mobiliser en faveur de
rodorkovski chaque jour ils sont venus
manifester devant le
tribunal parce que l'affireski c'est de
toute évidence un procès
politique mais même peu nombreux ces
trblons sont encore de trop pour les
autorités qui ont déployé un disposi de
sécurité démesuré
aud'h lire par son avocat une lettre
sorte d'engagement en politique dans
laquelle il dénonce ce qui au crremmelin
ont voulu sa perte il veulent
m'emprisonner le plus longtemps possible
pour casser ma volonté de vivre d'être
libre et de
lutter à vrai dire personne n'est
vraiment surpris par la lourdeur de la
peine même pas sa mère je ne suis pas
étonné je sais dans quel pays je vis et
les parents du fils prodige devenu
ennemi numéro 1 sont repartis ils feront
appel mais sans grand espoir en
poursuivant ainsi Mel rodorkovski le
kremelin s'expose aux critiques de
l'étranger mais face à son opinion
publique il ne risque pas grand-chose
car les déboirs de l'exhom le plus riche
du pays laisse la plupart des Russes
indifférents et George Bush a indiqué ce
soir que l'affaire était suivie de très
près aux États-Unis notamment lorsque
Michel kodorkovski va faire appel en
bref derniers instants de campagne au
Pays-Bas où l'on vote demain pour ou
contre la Constitution européenne les
partisans du oui se démènent pour
convaincre les électeurs de ne pas
suivre l'exemple français le nom fait
toujours la course en tête dans les
sondages en Irak un message audio
attribué à Abou Moussa
balzarkawi a été mise en ligne sur le
site Internet du groupe islamiste le
leader d'alqaïda affirme qu'il n'a été
que légèrement blessé et il promet à la
poursuite de la Guera il réaffirme aussi
sa fidélité à Ben Laden par ailleurs le
procès de Saddam Hussein pourrait se
dérouler d'ici 2 mois déclaration du
président iraakien Jalal talebani à nos
confrères américains de CNN et puis en
Irak encore se quotidien notre conur
Florence obna et son guide husinanoun
sont retenus en otage depuis 146 jours
maintenant santé la journée
internationale sans tabac elle a lieu
chaque année à l'initiative de l'OMS
l'Organisation mondiale de la santé et
les autorités françaises veulent en
profiter cette année pour relancer la
lutte contre la cigarette après 4 ans de
baisse la consommation s'est en effet
stabilisée depuis le début de l'année
José blanc-
laapiierre 17,4 milliards c'est le
nombre de cigarettes vendues en France
cette année en 4 mois un chiffre qui ne
baisse plus par rapport à l'année
dernière où les ventes avaient chuté de
20 %. autre signe que l'arrêt de la
cigarette s'essouffle les ventes de
patch et de chewing-gum à la nicotine
100 million en 2004 500000 en 2005 sur 4
mois également et pour continuer à fumer
malgré l'augmentation du prix certains
nont les plus jeunes préfèrent
maintenant se les rouler
malheureusement ces fumeurs là jeunes ne
viennent pas à des consultations pour
s'arrêter sur fumé pourtant un vrai
petit miracle avait été réalisé l'année
dernière avec moins 30 % d'acro chez les
adolescentes et les moins de 14 ans
alors pour ne pas s'endormir sur ces
bons résultats voici bientôt sur vos
écrans une campagne qui rend la
cigarette ridicule sera-t-elle efficace
ça a l'air absurde comme ça trop tôt
pour le dire et pourtant fumer nuit
gravement au confort et la santé de
notre entourage à la veille de l'été la
présentation aujourd'hui au pompiers des
Alpes Maritimes d'un nouveau produit
retardant contre le feu c'est une
invention d'un laboratoire allemand
Olivier Teron sur
place on ne sent aucune
chaleur protection efficace à quelques
degrés du planétaé les pompiers font
leur marché ce nouveau produit associé à
l'eau présente des qualités stupéfiantes
ce polymère se transforme en gel
visqueux il s'accroche à toutes les
surfaces et surtout il emprisonne
l'oxygène constituant une barrière
antieu cette épaisseur là va avoir un
effet refroidissant très important elle
va diminuer la température ambiante
parce qu'en cas de feu la chaleur elle
est très très importante et donc ça va
diminuer la la température ambiante ça
va empêcher
l'oxygène de rentrer donc dans dans dans
à travers ce film là et donc vous avez
un mur antifeu démonstration dans les
conditions d'incendie des branches de
pain particulièrement inflammables sont
traité au gel le bûcher à côté pourtant
virulant ne parviendra pas à l'enflammer
les pompiers y voient tout de suite une
utilité c'est un produit qui pourrait
très bien bien être utilisé en cas de
ligne d'arrêt et en cas de protection à
priori avant l'arrivée d'un feu après
avoir été adopté par les Autrichiens les
Portugais les Espagnols le gel allemand
espère conquérir les Français pas
seulement les pompiers mais aussi les
particuliers en zone à risque première
journée de travail d'intérêt général
pour Fabien btez le gardien de Marseille
et de l'équipe de France qui a été
sanctionné vous le savz pour avoir
craché sur un arbitre a donné des cours
à de jeunes joueurs près de Toulouse un
stage entre entre guillemets qui a
attiré beaucoup de curieux évidemment
Isabelle de Lyon David
Bress à ses jeunes gardiens il apprend à
bien se placer Fabien Bartz dispense
généreusement ses conseils faisant
contre mauvaise fortune bon cœur comme
travail d'intérêt général il y a pire et
le plaisir du football l'emporte sur
tout le reste ouais ouais je m' bien ave
les gamins c'est sympa aujourd'hui vous
êtes venu un petit peu contraint et
forcé quand même comment non non [__]
pour poser ce genre de question ême FO
de culotter le joueur de l'OM veut
oublier qu'il est ici pour se racheter
une conduite à la suite d'un crachat
contre un arbitre un mauvais geste qui
ne ternit pas son aura auprès des jeunes
de ce centre de formation heureux d'être
les premiers bénéficiaires de la
sanction je réalis pas encore la chance
que j'étais avec lui aujourd'hui mais
bon il est simple il est impressionnant
et moi ça restera mon idole toujours
parce que il a fait gagner l'équipe de
France c'est cette image de lui que les
jeunes veulent conserver et c'est avec
fierté qu'ils ont à ses côtés tennis la
nouvelle jeunesse de Marie Pierce à 30
ans la Française a battu la numéro 1
mondial in avenport et se is dans le
dernier carré à Roland Garos
qualification également de justinein
Nathanael de rinxin Mathias
Baro en ce moment elle dévore tout sur
son passage Marie piirce a de l'appétit
cet après-midi elle n'a fait qu'une
bouchée de la numéro 1 mondial l'inen P
sur le central tout le monde s'attendait
à un bras de fer serré entre les deux
joueuses mais les 15000 ectur assist
pour le plus grand bonheur un cavaler
seul de la
française tout cEIT de Mar c'est qu'elle
est toujours dangereuse sur un cours la
seule incertitude c'est de savoir sielle
va être géniale ou pas aujourd'hui elle
éta top elle a très bien
joué à dans la première manche la numéro
1 mondiale est balayée comme une vulg
[Applaudissements]
junior
us sur
[Applaudissements]
leconcentre mais c jourci il en faut
plus pour la
déstabiliser je à de voil la française
en deminale je vaesser de rester sol cal
prendre du plaisir sur le comme je fa
chaque match de faire mon mieux jeud
marffronter la rusov ici en haut de
l'écran tombe cet après-midi de la jeune
Bulgare de 15 ans
ccileeva on se prend déjà à rêver d'une
finale entre Pierce et Justine Hin tout
à l'heure la Belge a facilement dominé
Maria Charapova la Russe numéro 2
mondial chez les hommes la première
demi-finale opposera les deux favoris
Nadal et fedraire ce sera vendredi la
bourse jeanarcy comme chaque année
France télévision organise un concours
ouvert aux étudiants en journalisme avec
un contrat à la clé lauréa dans la
catégorie rédacteur Franck Genzo du CFJ
bravo à lui Théo Souman et jény brifa
rejoindront également les rédactions de
France 2 et France 3 pour quelques mois
et puis dans la catégorie journaliste
reporter d'images c'est Antonin broutard
du CFJ également qui remporte le prix et
rejoindra France 2 lui aussi bravo
Anthony aonin routard fin de ce journal
merci de l'avoir suivi tout de suite la
météo patrice Drevet 20h55 le papillon
un film pour la première fois en clair
avec Michel Serot minuit 10 dernier
journal Jean-Claude Renaud des 6h30
matin dans les cas de vérité Françoise
Laborde recevra Alain Madelin on se
quitte sur ces images de la nouvelle
Miss Univers on en parlait hier et bien
il s'agit de Nathalie Glebova cette
brune aux yeux verts de 23 ans d'origine
russe elle représente le Canada à
[Musique]
demain